someone says go back home what do you
tell them no I'm from from America so I
said what do they call themselves and
they say they call themselves Muslims
and I'm like what's Muslims this is the
life I should have always had my
daughter took shahada both my daughters
what you hear in the media is all false
my mother took shahada before she passed
away Muslim women we wear hijab because
that's the our way of honoring God this
is what I want that's what I want in my
life it's a nice peaceful life I
appreciate everything you guys are
really doing out here for this community
out here
it is what we need for you and me
peace
so we're here at the teen center with
techno relief College we're blessed
technology and the team is blessed to
partner with Dean Center here in
villaraco Florida
[Music]
from 700 to 1100 and you can't get no
place no cheaper it's just ridiculous so
that's what we're here we're here to go
ahead and give back to the community
seek the truth and you will find the day
is clear from the Muslim Community here
in Tampa getting involved to reach out
to the Greater Community here our
neighbors the not yet Muslims so we are
Distributing food we got some doctors
here let's go take a look no crime so we
got some food for the people thank you
thank you brother it is a pleasure to be
here and serve the humanity
[Music]
as you can see look cars are all
starting to line up here we're just
getting started
[Music]
peace
shall reach the small little small
little town in India in India
will create
peace is for all this is where literally
right in front of the dean Center not
officially open the doors are open here
now because it's a dire need to go and
help those in need but we can go ahead
and do our small part to the community
and people can get to know the Muslims
are here to help the community yeah so
we just was talking about this last
night and then all of a sudden I robbed
I said
get me some free food they just gave me
clothes for my brother look at this new
for my brothers they don't even know my
brothers and I got a book there's
nothing to learn this yeah
you got yourself a shirt did you get
yourself a sweet potato I give you this
book you know Muhammad Ali this is the
book that changed his life you know
Malcolm X this is the book that changed
his life so we're here to serve Humanity
serve the community you're part of the
community huh I look forward to uh
seeing you soon again all right all
right take care God bless
so let's take a lot first and then from
the bottom of my heart I thank you guys
for taking time and choose to come here
everyone
you can't take it with you when you go
or you can't take this with you when you
go and you can't take this with you when
you go brothers and sisters we're all
going to depart from this life and all
of our material possessions to our money
will stay behind but your reoccurring
investment in the dean Center will
continue to grow even when you leave
this light so go ahead and make that
reoccurring investment in a Masjid Mega
dollar Center that will benefit you in
this life and in the next click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of you
[Music]